are you gonna miss the first just tell
me if you're gonna miss the the smell of
wet fur kit Harrington million dollar
mishaps stinky costumes and the
inability to see or speak costumes can
be a nightmare do you think the struggle
is worth the fame and fortune well you
won't after this number one did you know
some of the worst costumes to wear in
Hollywood are the super suits due to the
fact Tom Holland had a mask under the
Spider-Man mask meant he couldn't just
slip the mask off for a quick drink
instead he had to drink through a straw
through the eye socket the helmet on the
first film really didn't work very well
he's had issues with basically every
Spider-Man suit though as the last one
there's no changes again I asked for a
zip and I didn't get one the iron spider
one being particularly frustrating
because the gauntlets were making it
tough to recreate the iconic flip pose
this hand thing irritates me that's why
when I shoot webs in the zoo I I don't
do this I do this number two would you
be willing to shave your head for a
million bucks Millie Bobby Brown's
baldness in stranger things is pretty
tough for her while she didn't mind
shaving her hair she's really found that
it was affecting her self-esteem as she
came into her teenage years so she
refused to keep shaving it and switched
to a wig instead of course self-esteem
wasn't the only reason she also refused
to shave it because she had other roles
in the pipeline that required hair
number three it was a Bittersweet moment
to cut this scene and everything
everywhere all at once one character was
to be disemboweled with a sword where
instead of Gore there was candy kinda
like a pinata we guess the designer said
we had a hard time doing it with
practical effects since the candy was
lumpy and it was hard to have it come
out smoothly so they animated the
sequence instead number four corsets are
like mini cages that stop you from
kicking butt Bobby Brown refuses to do
any sort of corsets these days because
it made the fight scenes in the first
Enola homes movie practically impossible
it was so frustrating for her she said I
had to prepare my body to breathe and to
move in the corset it's hard navigating
the choreography that you've learned so
well in your trainers and your leggings
and then switching up and putting an
underskirt on a skirt over that a corset
then you have your Petticoat then you
have your long socks then you have your
heels
etc etc number five why would anyone do
this to themselves at this point we are
certain you know about Jamie Campbell
Bauer spending 25 days getting into
makeup at over six hours in the makeup
chair but something you might not be
familiar with was remember that one
moment in stranger things where we see
Chrissy Cunningham's father tied to a
chair well the Prosthetics covering
actor Christopher strand's eyes and
mouth were applied offset head makeup
artist Amy L Forsyth said he couldn't
see he couldn't speak all he could do
was hear so he was driven to the set
with no sense of where he was and then
bound to a chair this left him with very
few ways of communicating with anybody
all he could do was nod so it was all
yes or no questions number six boldness
in the face of nakedness is far more
intimidating than bravery in armor now
that sounds like an inspirational quote
while stellen Skarsgard liked how he
looked super intimidating naked as the
baron in Dune it wasn't easy to pull off
the suit was so hot that he had to have
a cooling pack inside of the prosthetic
but the part that was actually difficult
was when he was bathing in the oil the
suit would start to float so sadly in
order to get him dropped down properly
into the tub they had to carefully snip
the suit so that the liquid would weigh
him back down number 7. the whale Rife
with controversy had Brendan Fraser
doing some heavy lifting his Prosthetics
were so heavy he actually found himself
gaining muscle in places he didn't know
he had muscle in order to carry them
around every day and he constantly found
himself overheating saying there were
several layers and a cooling suit
similar to what race car drivers wear
its tubes that are crisscrossed and run
cold water over your body mastering the
right temperature was a challenge my
body melted eight bags number eight are
you happy with the changes they made to
gore for the movie Christian Bale
actually planned on saying no to playing
Gore the god butcher in Thor love and
thunder honestly for two tiny reasons
one was he was teeny tiny and in the
comics Gore is pretty buff and Bale was
currently thinned out for another roll
but he also didn't see any sense in
competing with Chris Hemsworth's body
and reason two was some teeny tiny
underwear he would have had to wear a
g-string because in the comics the
character only wears a cape and undies
and he just wasn't sure he could handle
that luckily taika was willing to talk
number nine in Edna Mode's 30 reasons to
not wear capes we can't remember smelly
and heavy being listed as reasons why
they're so terrible but that wasn't the
case for Game of Thrones Kit Harington
who in every season was gifted a heavier
Cape the weight of the cape reflects his
character's status so as he becomes more
respectable than he was when the show
began so too are heavy the shoulders
that wear the cape the costume designer
Michelle hates actors obviously number
10. too many layers to address can make
for a really long shoot day Millie
Alcock was struggling with her dress
from House of the Dragon it's literally
like this because the dresses were
uncomfortable and I've got a bad back
quit your complaining kit Harrington at
least you could sit properly with a cape
on number 11. yes that's Lily's actual
waste in Cinderella she's held together
by a corset that's too tight for her and
a diet of only soup in order to stay in
it she described it as it was like
torture it was so tight and delicate we
wouldn't be surprised to find out if
she'd been having dizzy spells on set
would you dare step into a dress that
compresses your every organ number 12
Rafe finds hated his Voldemort costume
in Harry Potter because everyone would
walk up to him and say got your nose he
was just getting sick of it kidding but
he was relieved to finally get the
costume off one reason was the tights he
had to wear kept falling and they were
irritating him Rafe joked sometimes when
the stunt team are getting too Macho I
would tease them with my inner thigh
number 13. diamonds aren't a girl's best
friend Carrie Mulligan for the great Gat
to be admitted it was a little bit of a
relief stick of the diamond I felt sort
of a waste of responsibility wearing
them the Tiffany and Company diamonds
were worth so many millions that she had
to be shadowed by a security guard they
were created specifically for the
character too she said there'd be
diamond bracelets on each arm and
diamond earrings and rings and strings
of pearls around my neck and I could see
this guy in the corner watching me
intently in case I ran off with anything
she did end up breaking the String of
Pearls she wore a few times so the only
thing she's guilty of is breaking the
property not stealing it number 14 when
you find out how Jayla went to the
bathroom the whole thing kind of loses
its Mystique poor Jennifer Lawrence was
practically nude in her X-Men costume
something she was definitely not a fan
of but going to the bathroom was next
level in all that blue makeup she had to
use a funnel so as to not leave the
toilet seat blue or herself needing
touch-ups Rebecca Romaine had quite the
experience too saying one time director
Brian Singer opened the tent where I was
literally bent over a chair getting my
crack touched up and I was like don't
come in here Brian you don't need to see
this and he said you really need some
white wine and he brought me some all of
this makeup takes up to eight hours per
day so you better be on your A-game if
you want to go home at a reasonable time
is all we're saying number 15 which is
scarier live action Maleficent or the
animated one Angelina Jolie's costume
was too scary for other Toddlers and
would make them cry so in the end they
cast her actual daughter to play Aurora
man that would be a really tough day in
the audition room maybe there are some
good reasons actors hate their costumes
but we know we've only brushed the
surface are there any costume nightmares
you've heard about that we didn't
include share them with us in the
comments